E' uscito qualcosa la ah no - Ma dove? No che stai dicendo?
- La vedi quella linea? Pensavo fosse tipo un popup della macchinetta - E invece era la libreria? - La libreria dietro
- Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una puntata di Vita Buttata
il tema della puntata di oggi è "Come
rimorchia la gente"
Per una puntata così importante ho pensato di invitare
all'interno degli studios de casa mia una
persona che ormai è diventata un pochino una
stella polare di questo programma, ma che
allo stesso tempo è l'unico ospite che
è finito in una puntata che a un certo
punto è scomparsa. Diciamo che questa persona però mi ha
permesso di conoscere Mark
Caltagirone, quindi le sono doppiamente
grato sia per questa opportunità
che per il fatto di essersi prestata a
tornare all'interno degli studios de
casa mia, sto parlando di Martina Pinto
- Yeee. Sono appena tornata da Ibiza - Ecco perché, non avevi sbagliato fondotinta - No sono abbronzata
Anche tu - Sai perché sono un po' abbronzato io? - Eh, hai fatto giardinaggio? - No, ho fatto beach volley
- Madonna quanto mi fa ridere questa cosa che giochi a pallavolo - E tu scusami cos'è che fai nella vita?
Quel è il tuo sport? - Faccio dei circuiti da sola a casa - Ah, per terra spalmata
con un tappetino? Si - Ah, a me a ridere questo, pensa un po' - Mi passi quel computer...
- Tu però c'hai proprio il c**o da pallavolista - Che vuol dire? - A panettone
- Oddio, ma ce la facciamo tutta così? Grande Marti! Tu non hai un cervello da colibrì allora!
"Così, da Ferrero Rosher - Tra l'altro volevo dire che Guglielmo questa volta mi ha lasciata a digiuno
- Per farvi capire cosa fa Martina appena
arriva "Ciao, oddio c'ho fame! Oddio c'ho fame!
Dove sono i cornetti? Posso fare il caffè? Suonerò il pianoforte!
Ma si può suonare il pianoforte senza saper suonare il pianoforte? - No Martina - Ok eccolo eccolo!"
Quindi tu arrivi a inizio registrazione che la vuoi uccidere
e che fai partire rec solamente per staccarla dal pianoforte
Ma siamo leggermente spostati a destra? - Anch'io ci vedo tutti verso di la...verso il pianoforte!
Vediamo se riusciamo a fare così. Sisi va bene così
- Ciao Gu e ciao ospite, il mio ex ha cercato di riconquistarmi dicendomi
"Ey, ti va di fumare un sigaro in pelle? Non penso ci sia altro da aggiungere
- Comunque sta cosa del membro ce l'avete un po' tutti eh! - Si, c'è un po' un'ossessione
- Etero, gay, qualsiasi cosa, sto c***o di c***o che vi hanno messo in mezzo alle gambe
lo dovete propinarcelo. "Lo ovete propinarcelo" - "Lo dovete propinarcelo". Tranquilla, tranquilla Martina
Tranquilla - E' allucinante - Viviamo in una società fallocentrica, è vero quando dicono che... - Stai partendo
con del femminismo? - No, che la ... piace a molti ma il ... piace a tutti
- Ciao Gu ciao ospite, un ragazzo ha cercato di
rimorchiarmi dicendo
"Hey bella, ti pozzo offrire un cocktail?"
"Hey bella, ti pozzo offrire un cocktail?". Che sarà stato siciliano? - Ho capito, se in Sicilia si parla così...
- Abbiamo già iniziato una diatriba - Oddio non glie la faccio!"
- All'interno di questa casa è presente
una persona che in questo momento non  potete vedere
che è un fotografo e si
chiama, lo dici tu quel nome - Nago
" Mi ha fatti troppo soffrire!". Sostiene che si dica... - Arancina - L'hai detto! - L'ho detto!
Io so che questa cosa scatenerà... - L'inferno - L'inferno sotto
i commenti e che il tema del video scomparirà. Io ho bisogno di capire, si dice arancino
o arancina? - Però da siciliani c'avete ste
cose de Catania Palermo
Da romana io ho sempre detto arancino - Grande! Grande! (Gianmarco)
- "Ma somiglia a un'arancia". Certo perché le arance le friggi - C'è un'altra parola che cambia
a parte la Sicilia, cioè un'altra parola che... - Il Sicilio (Nago) - Il Sicilio
- Che in un posto si dice in un modo e un altro si dice in un altro...eh?
Che bella spiegazione! - Comunque la cosa positiva è che di base
son boni, basta che ti li magni - Comunque non è bello parlare di cibo in un giorno in cui mi
lasci... - ♬In un giorno qualunque, dove non mangi tu...Mangi, mangi con i piedi ♬
- Ciao Gu, io volevo raccontarti di quella volta in cui un ragazzo
mi scisse in chat che assomigliavo a Nino D'Angelo
- Io lo amo Nino D'Angelo però, comunque è un fico!
- Ma era un modo per dirle usciamo? - "Sei bellissima!
Assomiglia a Nino D'Angelo". Adesso vediamo se assomigli a Nino
D'Angelo, vagamente. Hai degli occhi chiari come
Nino D'Angelo - No - Vabbè poverino forse era
ubriaco quando ti ha detto questa cosa
- Non assomigli a Nino D'Angelo, però è un bellissimo messaggio da ricevere
A me dicono che assomiglio a Jack Black - E' vero - E' vero. Un tempo me ne dicevano di più fichi
- E ma poi ha spanzato proprio Jack Black (Gianmarco)  - Ah perché io no - Te hai passato periodi peggiori
comunque, quando ci siamo conosciuti era proprio un periodo peggiore
Però io ti amavo lo stesso - Certo! - Inizialmente mi dicevano Zac Efron
- Se ciao ma dove?! - Ma vaff...E Ashton Kutcher - Eh Ashton Kutcher si un po' - Secondo me zero!
Lui è figo! Guarda che Jag Blek, Jag Blek... - "Cottel", "Ti pozzo offrire un cottel?"
Ciao Gu ciao ospite, allora io non se questa possa essere considerata... - Ha la r moscia!
- Che vuol dire "Ha la r moscia"? - Ma tu te li ricordi i video che facciamo insieme?
E' vero me lo ricordo pure io (Gianmarco) - Perché ti piace la r moscia? - Si
- Non lo sapevo, non me lo ricordavo, piacere Guglielmo
- Una tecnica di rimorchio... - "Rimorchio" bellissimo! - I vicini di casa
del mio ragazzo si sono conosciuti in un supermercato, quando lei ha
iniziato a miagolare verso di lui e lui ha risposto abbaiando - Che teneri! Che teneri? - "Wof wof"
- Io so fare bene il cane
- Sai quand'è che sei più brava? Quando ti
dicono "Azione" - ...Lo sapevo!
- Questa gli miagolava contro e questo qui rispondeva abbaiando? - Si sono capiti subito, quella è stata
proprio la chimica. Sono andati a convivere e hanno preso un cane e un gatto e lo hanno chiamato come
il supermercato. Che ne so, tipo Conad e...Euro Spin - Vuoi dire Con Ad
- Tu come rimorchi la gente? - Rimorchio? Brava! Io non
rimorchio. Cioè sei te che devi... - A me bastano gli occhi, tipo il barista di ieri
Magari lo guarderà pure, ciao barista. Eh sono andata a pagare, l'ho guardato negli occhi, ho detto "Quant'è?
E poi ho abbassato lo sguardo per prendere i soldi e lui fa "Fammeli rivedere". Io "così"
- O magari chiedeva di rivedere... - I soldi - I soldi - Il mio rimorchio è sicuramente questo
"Ammazza sei simpatico! Carino" - E' per quello che non ci siamo mai fidanzati
Esatto! Penso "Almeno lascio un graffio, così vengo ricordato
- Bravo. Male. Na tragedia - Si. Tu come rimorchi? - Sono solo me stessa - E speri quindi che le persone
ci provino - Non lo so sinceramente, non me l'hanno mai fatta questa domanda
- Ciao Gu ciao ospite ciao tutti, sono entrata in un
negozio per chiedere delle informazioni su
delle scarpe
e il commesso mi guardava insistentemente le tette e mi diceva "Hai dei capelli bellissimi!"
In realtà avevo dei capelli bellissimi, però mi guardava le tette
- Hai pise...hai pisello? Hai pisella? - Facello facello
- Io questa cosa però non l'ho mai capita, nel
senso ma le ragazze, non credo a te, se ne
rendono così tanto conto quando gli guardano le tette      - Perché non lo chiedi a me?
Guarda che le mie tette piacciono un botto - Ma ti stanno così?
- Mi guardano gli occhi. Forse è stato un lapsus, ha detto capelli invece di tette
- Chi va dal commesso e gli dice "Oh belle bocce signorina"
Ciao Gu ciao ospite, una sera ero a ballare e mi è capitato di essere bloccata da un ragazzo
e mi fa "Scusa scusa, hai perso il mio numero" e mi porge un pezzo di carta con il suo numero
- Ce l'ho! - No non ce l'hai - Ero su un volo, lo stewart viene, mi porta il coso da bere così
ripassa con un tovagliolo, io non glie l'ho chiesto sto tovagliolo, lo apro e c'era scritto "Hai degli
occhi", k, "Hai degli occhi bellissimi" e sotto il suo numero di telefono. Io sono uscita dall'aereo "così"
- Io sai che credo di essermi pentito di averti invitata proprio per questo qui
Quindi tutti quanti amano i tuoi occhi? - Beh di certo non le mie tette -... -Dai però scrivi occhi con le k!
Ma che c'è dai! - No non puoi farlo! E' come se scrivi apposta con due p
- Errico - "L'hai fatto apposta"- Enrico oggi non è con noi
Anche a me è successo una volta, ma sono stati bravissimi
ero in treno, me ne torno a casa, e a un
certo punto aprendo, non mi ricordo se era
un'agenda, una cosa così... - Te l'hanno lasciato dentro - Cioè praticamente ho fatto proprio...è caduto
Quelle cose da film che dici "Si ma è impossibile!" - Ma c'era un numero di telefono? - Si si, un numero con
dedichina si - Che carino!
- A me mette molto in imbarazzo perché poi dico "Eh ma se ti scrivo...cioè anche solo per ringraziare
automaticamente apri un canale - Certo - Finisci per prendere in giro o comunque
per dare delle false speranze - Vabbè uno potrebbe anche scrivere grazie - Tu hai ringraziato? - Macché!
- Ciao Gu ciao ospite, stavo studiando, a un certo punto un ragazzo di fronte a me mi passa il suo
telefono e dentro c'era scritto "Ciao senti ti ho visto, sei carina bla bla bla", io ho risposto a voce, e niente lui
continuava a rispondermi scrivendomi per messaggio     - Era muto - Non mi era mai capitata una cosa del genere
è stato assurdo, letteralmente - Magari non poteva parlare
- Infatti non ti è venuto in mente che magari non potesse parlare?
- Ma non era muto era solo un cazzone (Gianmarco) - Ho capito però se
lei ti risponde a voce tu rispondi a vo...vorse aveva una brutta voce - O magari era un giochetto che si era
creato, tu subito tragica, Clara sulla sedia a rotelle - La persona peggiore nei modi di approccio che io conosca
sono io, per il semplice fatto che io non
approccio, sono una persona
orgogliosissima e tende a non fare mai
il primo passo, a meno che si trova
la ragazza che gli piace che glie la sbatte in faccia
- In tutti i sensi...andiamo avanti, vediamo se
aggiunge a questa colorita, diciamo
descrizione - Quanta poesia - Poi ovviamente mi flagello
peggio della passione di Cristo, quindi niente probabilmente andrò a fare un
corso di tuffi e provarmi a buttare - Mamma mia questa usala! E' un poeta - E' un piskelletto dark
- Dark? Non è vero - La Dark Polo Gang, madonna come sei antiquato però, vecchio!
- Uno che segue la Dark Polo Gang - Ma non erano gli Evanescence tipo dark? O Madonna nel video di Frozen?
- In Italia la parola Dark ha un altra accezione (Gianmarco) - Cioè se tu sei Dark non sei
tutto nero...? - Adesso non più - Dark adesso è quello ma perché è riferito alla Dark Polo Gang
non perché è riferito al dark nel senso ... tutti così
♬La mia faccia sopra un magazine, magazine...Adesso la tua t***a mi conosce bene ♬ - Ah ok
Ragazzi siamo  arrivati alla fine di questo
video, io ringrazio ancora Martina
- L'altro era molto più bello - Non è vero, questo qui è venuto benissimo
il problema è che non andrà mai online
- Però nell'altro spiegavo come fare una... - Perché ti stai massaggiando il c**o? - Per la puntura
- Vabbè spiega come si fa la puntura anche qui, vai            - Prendete la chiappa
la dividete in quattro. Fai la chiappa. Questa è la chiappa. Eh c'è il microfono davanti, mettiti più in la
La dividete in quattro
quattro, la dividete in quattro, quindi così,
in quadranti - Smettila di dividerla, ho capito!
Il primo quarto in alto a destra o in alto a sinistra, quindi in alto esterno, lo ridividete in quattro e
ficcate l'ago qua - Martina grazie quindi doppiamente anche per questo corso di punture
Io ringrazio anche voi per aver madato i vostri messaggi e aver contribuito a questa
rubrica ma allo stesso tempo per aver
portato, oddio, questo video fino a qui
Fatemi sapere quali sono stati dei modi orribili che le persone hanno usato per rimorchiarvi
Iscrivetevi a questo canale, attivate la campanellina delle notifiche per non perdere
le prossime uscite ma soprattutto ci vediamo il prossimo giovedi sempre alle 14
con un altro Vita Buttata. Che stai facendo?
Ti va di cantare una canzone? Qual è una canzone dove sei molto brava? - Tutte, basta che è in italiano
Eh inglese non so se so le parole giuste, le posso inventare dai - Vai
♬ parole a caso ♬
♬ Aleuia...Arancino... - Ho detto un'arancina!